[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voir des enfants
venons de faire un très beau voyage nous
avons survolé de haute montagne et
visiter un magnifique pays qui s'appelle
le tyrol et nous avons aussi fait la
connaissance du cousin de nounours oui
de mon cousin germain panne ce qui
laissera pas tic mon cousin pense pas
trop
très sympathique nounours et il m'a
appris le jolie chanson je descend vite
la chanter à nicolas ya pa pr neil mon
échelle hop hop hop hop hop hop
les voilà loup
va pas recommencer à parler on sait pas
où rth petit rôle d'homme aux bons soins
de nom qu'est ce que tu nous as apporté
c'est quoi ces gros paquet je vous ai
rapporté plus nous serons son loup c'est
tout non je pose mon carton
je louvre puis voilà un beau chapeau
tyrolien pour pape rhône elle
je vais l'essayer un mois alors un
chapeau tyrolien deux garçons
il te plait oh merci non ce qui est
tragique c'est un chapeau d'homme comme
le mien tu m'en vais l'essayer
uma chaussons
[Musique]
c'est une tyrolienne
tu sais elle est très amusante à
chansons et tu en as une drôle de voix
c'est comme ça qu'on chantait tyrolienne
renault je ne peux presque plus à
vigueur posément pauvre nounours bonne
nuit tyrolien
te fatigue pas là
j'éteins la lumière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bravo notre nounours est très doué il
chante très bien des tyroliennes nous
lui demanderons encore de nous enchanter
bourse ou soir pour tous
une autre photo oui mon cher nounours
bonne nuit les enfants allez vite vous
coucher n'oubliez pas de faire votre
toilette de bien vous laver les dents
[Musique]
et
vous
[Musique]